The project that the New York times was given the pullets, uh, uh,
for this year of recasting the history of the United States in terms of
slavery as the primary narrative,
the 1619 project seems to me just to be fundamentally historically
wrong. It's a distortion.
This isn't to say that slavery didn't matter.
It just doesn't mean it's not important.
It's just that if you were to try to explain the significance of the
United States to a visiting Marsh,
and you wouldn't start with slavery,
because that wasn't really an especially unique feature of the
United States, there was slavery and it lasted much longer in Brazil. Uh,
there were slavery and it was far harsher in the Caribbean, uh,
colonies of Britain than other European States.
So what's the defining characteristic.
What's the thing that makes the United States distinctive.
It's not slavery.
[Inaudible].
Historian's perspective.
What do you think that the average American should know about the
history of America that we don't know or that we underappreciate, because,
you know, we seem to live in a time where we're,
we're erasing our own history and we're taking down monuments and we're,
you know, destroying the names of people that were flawed,
but that were just people of their time.
Well, I think the, the challenge here is, uh,
that history is not, uh, it's not monochrome, uh,
the history of any great society or state can't be
told, uh, as a eulogy,
not nor as a kind of criminal indictment and the good
historian, uh,
of the United States or for that matter of the United Kingdom,
acknowledges that there are, uh,
debits as well as credits that there is there's shadow,
there's dark sides to the story as well as bright sides. And this is, uh,
a challenge that I,
I didn't think was difficult when I was writing early in my
career. I wrote a history of the British empire,
which included a chapter on the American revolution. And, uh,
the book sets out very plainly, uh, the,
the many stains on the history of the British empire, including, uh,
of course the, uh, the central role of slavery in the,
in the Southern colonies that became the Southern States of the
United States. Uh,
but the point of that book and I'd make the same argument about the history of
the United States is that the,
the benefits weighed the costs that the successes
were more important ultimately than the failures.
The project that the New York times was given the pullets, uh, uh,
for this year of recasting the history of the United States in terms of
slavery as the primary narrative, the 60 19 project,
it seems to me just to be fundamentally historically wrong.
It's a distortion,
this isn't to say that slavery didn't matter.
It just doesn't mean it's not important.
It's just that if you were to try to explain the significance of the
United States to a visiting Martian, yeah.
You wouldn't start with slavery because that wasn't really an especially unique
feature of the United States.
There was slavery and it lasted much longer in Brazil. Uh,
there were slavery and it was far harsher in the Caribbean colonies of Britain
and other European States. So what's the defining characteristic.
What's the thing that makes the United States distinctive.
It's not slavery, uh,
any more than if you looked at Western civilization broadly, uh, uh,
it would be true to say that imperialism's the defining characteristic.
Everybody did empire just as slavery goes way back before 60 19,
all the way to ancient times. And by the way, still exists,
there is still slavery. There are slave markets, uh,
where people are sold. There are slave economies,
which rely on slave labor today.
So it can't really be true to say that the interesting thing,
the thing you really need to know about the United States is slavery.
But the interesting thing about the United States is that it represented an
experiment in governance, uh,
a radical experiment based on ideas from the enlightenment and earlier
ideas from the Protestant reformation. It's fair to say. And,
and this produced an extraordinary constitution,
which has stood up to, uh, all the stresses and strains, uh,
of, uh, of history since, uh,
the late 18th century and understanding that peculiar
constitution, that very distinctive document with its separation of powers,
and it's careful preservations of individuals,
but that should be your top priority. If you're studying American history,
not to the exclusion of the bad stuff, there's plenty of bad stuff, uh,
that we need to study,
but I don't think we should be teaching young Americans from Howard Zinn's
people's history of the United States in which the negatives are constantly
emphasized over the positives.
That just seems to me to miss the point of the American story completely.
Are you worried that the extraordinary pressures that we're facing right now
between a pandemic between riots and protests between,
you know, polarization that really is,
is off the charts and then throw in social media,
which is just gas on the flame.
Are you worried that those pressures could snap that project in a way that it
hasn't been snapped before, or certainly in the last hundred years?
Dave, let me give you a somewhat surprising answer to that question.
I'd be worried if we weren't worried.
One of the things about this country that's very,
is that we're always worried that the Republic's going to end.
We're always kind of fretting about, uh, about the coming tyranny, uh,
the impending civil war, and, uh,
and thus far there's been one civil war and no dictatorships. Uh,
and that's kind of encouraging.
I think that's partly because we worry about this and I think it's a healthy
feature of American life also to expect decline. Uh,
people have been predicting the decline of the United States, uh,
throughout my life. Uh,
it was a preoccupation of Henry Kissinger whose biography I'm in the midst of,
of writing in the 1970s. It seems as if the United States was being torn apart,
uh, by Vietnam torn apart by its, uh,
racial divisions torn apart by a president who had violated his, uh,
his oath of office, all of that we've seen before.
And I think it's part of the way the United States works,
that we're always expecting the disintegration of the Republic and the descent
into civil war. And I,
I think we'll have to start being nervous if we stop worrying about that stuff.
But as long as we have my old friend, Andrew Sullivan,
so fretful about the coming Trump tyranny,
that he doesn't quite spot the tyranny of the left until it's right up behind
him. I mean, that, that's kind of the predicament that I think a lot of, uh,
liberals and conservatives find themselves in that they were so indignant and
dismayed by Trump back in 2016,
that they slightly underestimated that the rather more
operationally worrying, uh,
tyrannical tendencies of the radical left. Uh, so yeah,
I think we should keep worrying about this stuff.
And as long as we're worrying about it, we'll probably be okay.
Yeah. Does it also strike you as,
as odd or maybe obvious relative to social media that when something
happens here that it suddenly happens everywhere? I mean,
we've all seen the videos now of,
of literally police officers in London being hunted down by mobs that
has nothing to do in any concrete sense with what happened to
George Floyd. And yet it seems like if there's an incident here,
it's now exported everywhere.
I think future historians will wonder why it was that in the midst of
a pandemic, which is far from over Americans,
decided to have a debate about, uh,
police violence towards,
African-Americans not,
not to say that that's not an important issue to think about,
but it seems an odd time to have that debate and to start debates about
defunding the police.
When we should really be wondering what went wrong with the department of health
and human services and CDC,
when they ought to have taken far better and earlier action to
contain the contagion. There's something strange. It's a,
non-sequitur that in the midst of this massive public health crisis, uh,
which has killed nearly 120,000 Americans and will probably kill another 120,000
before the end of the year, we're having this, this debate.
But the second point I'd make is that the internet has created a
new kind of contagion. As I said earlier, quoting my son,
there are two pandemics and, and the second pandemic, uh, in fact,
predates the merger of, uh, of George Floyd,
because it's a pandemic of protest that you could actually see
in Hong Kong, uh, in Santiago, uh,
in Barcelona, in cities like Beirut last year. Uh,
and what is interesting to me is that the mode of protest is consistently the
same, the content varies from place to place,
but this quality of a protest to go viral styles of
protest to be co copied from Hong Kong, uh,
to Minneapolis is really interesting. I mean,
historically the police are better communications than demonstrators for most of
the second half of the 20th century, uh,
that the police had walkie talkies and the demonstrators were lucky if they had
megaphones, but the smartphone has changed that,
and it's allowed protesters to, to really organize these [inaudible] networks,
where there is no obvious leader and actually have superior comms to the police.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about academia,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our academia playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.